that
is what it means to be my shinobi
that was our little lord our young
prince
speaking invoking our shinobi's code of
honor
and imploring us to find him and bring
him back safely
but perhaps even more striking than our
lord's voice
is our own
the undead
in my last video we talked about the red
sheathed second blade
on sakiro's back something that was
touted as an unlockable weapon for
later in the game and this is it the
undead slayer
it's almost certainly a special type of
blade that's for killing
immortal beings and we'll talk about it
a little bit later
at the end of the video we hear our
young lord speak once again
and this time he's talking in a sort of
formal entreating
tone
along with my blood you must live so we
already know that our prince is special
because of his
blood that's why the ashina clan stole
him from us
in the first place and when he says live
along with my blood
he could simply be imploring us to sort
of fight for both of their lives
but he could also mean it in a
supernatural sense
it could literally be the blood that's
keeping us alive and from software
could be hinting at something
supernatural again that
our two lives are very intertwined
there are three other characters voiced
in the trailer
the first is the woman with the red
umbrella
she says i have witnessed
[Music]
once before might have a bit of a double
meaning
the more conventional interpretation is
that she has witnessed a scene
of great carnage once before for example
this could be referenced to the burning
village in the intro
she could be talking about all the
terrible devastation that
usually follows war alternatively though
ashura
is also a type of wicked demigod
in buddhist mythology sort of a type of
anti-god or
demon that's often depicted get this as
having six
arms sound familiar i reckon it's likely
that we've signed a bit of a
deal with the devil here but moving on
it's been a while brat of the owl
this is a curious statement the words
it's been a while
suggest that our character has a history
with this woman
or at least that we've met her before
she calls us a brat
she's rude but who or what
is the owl it could be our clan it could
be
our lord it could be our god nobody
knows
but she's not the only one who speaks
mockingly to our shinobi
we also have this guy am i getting in
your way
shinobi of the air this could also be
interpreted as
you would block my path shinobi of the
air and
this character isn't seen in the trailer
but can i just say
both this man and our shinobi have voice
actors that sound
so so similar to the voice actors of
guts
from berserk and if you've watched
berserk
which you really should you'll
understand how bloody fitting this is
anyway those were just the translations
now let's dig into the weapons the
bosses and
the environments we open on the burning
village scene which
is something that we've seen a few times
now so it must be a pretty important
story event
ashinobi lies beaten on the floor
and our little lord talks about how
death should not stop us from rescuing
him
and then we're up on our feet and we're
sprinting past a flag
featuring a pretty complex kanji that
likely
references a kura okami which
is a sort of dragon god residing in the
mountains
or mysterious rain dragon
this valley serpent that we saw in the
e3
trailer he does fit the bill but with
the translations i'm told
we shouldn't jump to conclusions because
we're missing a ton of context
and our translations could be a little
bit inaccurate as a result
in the next scene we stealth over some
enemies who are
sitting and pouring over a map and it's
definitely worth noting that
sakiro so far has made a big effort to
make sure that their enemies are
actually
acting like they belong in their
environments they're not just
standing around most of the time and
then there's this
wall jumping so you could not do this in
the gamescom demo
so it must be one of those unlockable
skills that sikiro can develop
add it to the list and remember if we
can endlessly jump between walls like
this
then that should also mean that we're
able to endlessly bounce
on top of enemies as well three monks
walk through a
tranquil sun-drenched forest which is a
sort of warm
setting that we haven't actually
explored before
in a from software game you can still
see the sunlight
filtering through as we head inside
actually
and here sequito is showing off how
bloody fast it's possible to block
attacks in this game
he gets perfect blocks on every one of
these by tapping
the l1 button he isn't just holding it
down
this is a trick wall which functionally
will be replacing illusory walls
except i'm sure they're used for stealth
as well this is followed by the woman
with the red umbrella
who actually peers over the cliff here
this gave me a bit of patches ptsd but
then i remembered
wait we don't take fall damage in sikiro
what is patch is gonna do
he's gonna have to up his game and then
we have
shkiri undead slayer i'm sure most of
you have played the witcher series
so i bet this second blade reminds you
of the second silver blade that geralt
wields in that game
in the witcher geralt has a second
silver blade that is way more effective
against
monster type enemies and it seems like
this undead slayer weapon
will be better against unnatural maybe
immortal creatures in sikhiro
and perhaps it'll be able to unlock
special moves as well
there was actually a consumable item in
the demo that i didn't talk about much
it was called divine confetti and if you
used it
you spread it around yourself and it
dispelled darkness but the description
says
that it assists in fights against ghost
type
enemies and clearly a big thing in
sikiro
is going to be stealthing around and
discovering the weak points of your
enemies
and divine confetti that lets you hit
ghost type enemies and
a second sword that allows you to hit
mortal enemies
is perfectly aligned with that sort of
philosophy
and now since we've gone from one weapon
to two weapons
why not three at first glance that looks
like we're wielding a spear
instead of a sword but it's actually not
a main hand weapon
it's a prosthetic weapon that sort of
starts off as this tiny blade on your
wrist
but then the shaft extends mid attack to
a ridiculous length it pins a far away
enemy
it pulls them up close to us and then
sikiro performs an
art that is called iaido which is sort
of a
smooth controlled attack where you're
able to pull your sword out of its
scabbard
and attack in one smooth motion the
attack itself has a sort of
milky white streak to it and i don't
really know what to make of that
but this guy crawling away on all fours
he wants none of it
next the japanese symbol for smoke
and then in the gamescom demo there was
an item
called fistful of ash which you could
chuck at an enemy and
it would basically have the same
function as this red cloud
it allows you to re-enter stealth and it
allows you to make your escape
and you should make no mistake this sort
of execution attack
could be an entire new category of
unlockable
skills i bet it's not just limited to
this one imagine
how many other types of unlockable
execution skills there could be
and then we have this incredible
cinematic scene
where an old woman boss dashes
confidently
on threads as thin as spiders silk you
can see them
flashing here it's worth noting that
this actually takes place
in the burning temple that we've seen a
few times now
and this was a place that we speculated
might actually be
the hub world of sikiro and is anyone
going to talk about how
fast these enemies are attacking timing
your blocks to some of these attacks is
gonna be like playing osu on max
difficulty it's
pretty much a rhythm game at this point
and then
we have the corrupted monk which shows
itself so
i can finally talk about it this was the
gamescom boss that we weren't allowed to
show you guys
and man this was such a good fight you
only see
a couple of elements of the fight here
unfortunately
we see this grey mist illusion phase
that you can actually sort of avoid by
swinging between the branches
and just waiting it out and here you see
sekiro doing an execution
and taking off one of the three health
bars
that the monk has but what you don't see
is the entire rhythm
of this fight the boss actually has a
attack pattern that's really similar to
the dancer
in dark souls 3 it's sort of relentless
and
flowing and it takes a really long time
to wear down her posture
to the point where you can actually do
an execution like this
honestly i think since you can die so
many times in sikiro
they've balanced that out by making the
boss fights really
really long and i wouldn't be surprised
if most boss fights
were long like this one is to finish a
white ape
with a big old blade stuck through its
neck throws us to the ground
and the trailer ends i can't wait
before i go i have to give special
thanks to all of the translators who
have offered their help to the community
in translating your skills are going to
be in really high demand
as we explore sikiro special thanks to
patrons
as always thanks for watching and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
foreign